naja eigentlich hätten sie schon längst
hier sein müssen aber sind die
außenseiter
ich ziehe die man da mal raus
wie ist die lage bei christoph die lage
ist blond und hat riesen brüste ne
quatsch ist alles entspannt
alfdorf supermann dass wir endlich mal
von mir eingeladen wurden wurde aber
auch so zu beginn war eine ganz
innovative frage wie schafft er es
eigentlich so ein mega erfolg auf
youtube zu haben na ja die leute mögen
uns weil wir so cool sind du
nehmen die mädchen die würden am
liebsten mit uns wirklich mal auch endet
immer möglich herbert jetzt nervt nicht
mädchen möchte jetzt halt die klappe wir
ihn zu hause über das thema
so laut dass das mädchen kommt
alles auf
mädchen an mädchen oder zwei medien und
dann benimmt sich herbert
genial woher habt ihr eigentlich diese
ganzen irren einfälle
wie gehen eben öfters aufs klo du hast
mich das nicht will getan das hat nicht
wehgetan
du bist eine puppe sie kennen keinen
schmerz ich bin keine puppe ich bin
super man
die konnte dort machen
sensationell sein interview mit euch
noch klar sehen meine brille bitte
britischen
uns dann mal vom acker bis dann ein
echtes echt
das könnte ich mir vorstellen